it can be boring at times but we look at
detail we don't we don't look at the
cardiovascular training
that should potentially say that'll come
naturally as you get better speed should
increase in a natural way
so
when i was in iran
you pray for the hour
the clock on the air you go faster it's
kind of
changing this floor is softer than
and being in japan he didn't explain a
lot he just
demonstrated to the yokama and then
attacked you know attacking me through
the demonstration a couple of times and
you just go
and sort of stand back
and you do it for 10 minutes non-stop
and it was blinking hard training
and i
went there and this was he said tony if
you want your fifth day you've got to
come to obama this time
he's sort of put these pressure on me
because uh
on an earlier seminar somewhere in the
world
he said all my walmart
students out the front he said
demonstrating
and i stood back and he shouted at me
and go telling him
and afterwards he said don't ever do
that again
i said sensei but i didn't think
he said you've traveled all around the
world to see me
you're the one with didn't but he then
said
that he wanted the dojo for your fit
there
so when i went there i couldn't
understand why he wasn't explaining
everything
and then mars kessler you might have
heard of he explained to me that um ah
that's where it says he's so clever he
knows that the westerners wants
lots of questions
and lots of answers to those questions
so what he does is he switches hats
he gives the people the westerners all
the information plus the techniques he
gives the japanese a demonstration
because they're a nation of copies
they can copy really well and it gives
them nothing as far as feedback goes
so my dad without realizing i had the
best of both worlds
and
i realized that
if you don't really want to go to armor
if you want to learn
because you just get beaten up there
you become very good but you know you're
going to need new hip replacements and
needed places
so
let's have nick and your partner
doing miroti dorm
now you don't have to hold strong
but but because they don't
matthew say out loud
when you feel that nick is
dominating or taking over your comfort
see he's really comfortable now oh god
him
i've got a grip on him now so he's
confident leave him confident means that
you've attempted him because
his mind thinks that he's win
he's got to leave matthew with that
thought all the way through now
matthew's going to say when he thinks
that that has changed do you understand
it okay
the change changed
so now
bulk is hitting bulk
so nick's got to find a way of not
letting
matthew be disturbed because what
matthew's going to do
it's built in us he's going to try and
hang on because
he can't see behind him he might not
like hitting the floor especially with
no max and this is another reason why i
didn't bring the mats
and you know as big as you are as old as
you are you don't want to be you don't
want to fall backwards dude or we
perhaps you do obviously you don't care
you don't have to grip strong all i'm
saying is sensitivity would tell you
well if you blocked him there
wouldn't you say
i felt it so you should have said yeah
okay
this is
so nick might be here
until 4 30 and we go what a great day we
had we're just watching it right there
oh
so he's
he's
this person he's not being attempted
anymore because he's
realized that
the guy's trying to fight him
so the technique's not working
so let's go through that okay
hi
yeah there
so so what you're doing is you're doing
everything correct believe it or not
he's doing everything correct but what's
happening is he's dropping his shoulder
he's going soft but now he's
he's decided to go in
but he didn't tell me to go in
so if i'm the puppet of the attacker and
using his strength
i've got to think
are you still happy that you're
comfortable
and i didn't lock his mouth
so i'm going to just creep this leg
behind
and it's difficult
and i'll look this one bend that one's
straight so i'm gonna just slowly creep
up his body
with this nice likeness you see he's
still feeling comfortable
you see
now
you might not this might not be a
successful one kaitenagi might have been
a bit more successful but i just want
you know here's your partner he's going
to give you feedback all you've got to
do is say block that's going to bug your
ego because you don't like being told
what to do
but you're going to have to live with
that bit
because it's going to be telling you
that your aikido is not perfect just yet
all right
[Music]
how long has it been off maybe maybe it
turns off without um you know with
inactivity i know sometimes
maybe
so it's not been on the tour uh i just
noticed that just then so
it should be okay i mean
i picked up the audio
[Music]
because it wasn't recording last
okay
well nick would have got someone
but it's getting his
[Music]
you don't have to hold it strong
um
[Music]
okay
is
isn't it
right over there
now i want to relax the shoulder but i
mustn't try and bring him with me
because he won't want to come
so i can't take his mind so he's got
this i want to say to him i need you to
keep thinking that you've got this i'm
dissolving from matthew
i'm dissolving
him with these methods now i need to get
under that elbow so when i drew that
before
i'm showing you silly footwork but
i need matthew to be happy that he's got
me
and now what i'm going to do is i'm
actually just going to shift
nothing here i'm shifting my center
away
but to find this answer
i do it this way
but if you want to feel the benefits
since he used to say you've got to feel
good in jupiter
and then you come in
you go here you bring this and you come
up his
body and then the only way you can put
your arms out you don't need no power
here then with your hips are there the
only time you're going to need to put
your hands there in case this leg takes
a fire and takes your teeth out so
yeah so when you end up crossing that
it's for when you kick your legs that's
why you look the other way
so you're all wanting to go further
than what you should do
you need to be you need to be
without learning how
soft you can
do it
for the block i mustn't go in yet then
so what am i going to do
i want to go in
let's try and change my phone
oh that's a bit easier
you've got to change
what you think because you are the most
intelligent person you know
you know as far as
making a decision
we've got a flat it's just flooding can
you quickly send some people i'll get
back to you in a month or two
how long will these business last
so
we make decisions every day we've got to
now make them in seconds milliseconds
i've done everything i've showed you
but in
you still count
so i'm picking up
we'll say
mine to mine things my arm isn't in the
correct position where you want to be
but i said i don't need my arm i'm
trying
you should not be there
is
yes
okay
[Music]
okay don't you just hate it when they
block you yeah
so mark's gonna do it
because we've got a horrible person
don't train with him he blocks you
you know
he's not being taught at all well
to respect the person
so he's
the arm still looks like it's working
hard to never know what other people are
thinking it looks like his arm still
working hard even though his body's got
in all them i used to look like keep
going
alex
the next time you come if you come again
so what you're doing is
you know i said about this i don't give
him a centimeter i don't take it
you're giving far too much
by finding your own space
all right you've got to sort of work
within what you've got and you haven't
got a lot because he's holding him let's
try once more so this i'm talking to
everybody of course hopefully but so
he's got it in there but now by that
second move you actually give him too
much because you move and there wasn't
some kind of action
i mean it's as if like your puppet on a
string when they do that you got so even
when you go in
something's got to move that's connected
somewhere
if you just move in like that and
nothing happens and then you try and
make something happen there's a big
disjoint within the technique
but that's right well let's carry on
because you won't get it in a second so
it's not going to be showing it again
but this is the problem so i'm talking
to you all you're actually
trying to work out where to go yourself
you've forgotten that you've got a
partner
and the partners holding the road strong
oh god you don't worry
well i'm gonna just jump off and you
know hopefully you'll be able to stand
there and hold me when i'm sort of going
it's like that you've gotta keep
connecting
but you've got to do it sneakily
okay
what we normally do is uh the lockheed
will go
as long as i
soften
the back shoulders going to that corner
alex can feel it
but i've got to keep him feeling that
while i
go in
it vanished because
i moved but he still felt safe he still
feels safe
i'm gonna now have to sneak this behind
him but if i do this
now he's gonna he's got me
so as i sleep behind him i'm actually
just seeing a little bit more power not
doing anything but i'm actually blowing
my body up
i know he's got me up here
but he hasn't got me
down here
and that's the bit
he's still thinking i think i think i'm
all right and the next thing he's coming
out of the floor thinking
wow
that's the bit we all want we all want
to be thrown but we don't we want to be
the throwers
of the ookas going wow the same as i did
the type of sensitivity
i was there
because i didn't know how he threw me
because he left me alone
so
anybody got any other questions on it or
if you'll try again let's try it
don't be in a rush to go in but when you
do go in systematically
[Music]
the good thing is
is
so
yeah so what you do now is you soften
them
so we forget
[Music]
just
being blocked
and it's because
he wasn't
trying to mail the engine he's trying to
go in you see
he's trying to go in now see where this
arm is here
it doesn't look any shape of this person
here
so if you were thinking about this
person's shape where should mark have
gone
towards the window
so what he's done is he's like
entitlement when you go
like that one direction's there the
other director that's wrong so what you
do is you bring these two together like
that and as they get closer you
redirect their power what like you know
says you go like that
and you redirect it so what
he's done was he actually didn't
redirect his power he went into his
power so this shoulder needs to go back
there
where matthew is
no not quite
when i see this arm
matching up with this arm
that i don't know the angles like
this arm and this arm
is running in line
before it wasn't
so now
he can hold that tension that
he's given him he must hold that not in
the center of me outside me and he then
moves his body around that
hold
move
your body keep this don't keep this
going
it's all wrong
don't know about it but step behind you
but he's still strong
so what he does there is he keeps that
firm but he doesn't move this he forgets
he's got that now but he just says i
don't want to leave you powerful but i'm
not going to use you anymore
he now tries to straighten his front leg
so he's working on his legs and his hips
the arms don't need to work
and that's where all of you are going
well you're still using your arms too
much
so you're looking for
ah you're looking
for that
hey
can't take him a second will you can't
give him a centimeter
okay